bonjour à tous le monde fait face à un
moment de péril les mots alarmant du
chef de l'onu antonio guterres s qui
préside en ce moment une réunion de
l'assemblée générale des nations unies à
new york on nous annonce également un
sommet extraordinaire demain jeudi des
27 dirigeants européens c'est donc la
mobilisation générale face aux menaces
de vladimir poutine en ukraine bonjour
bruno daroux bonjour julien en cette fin
de journée l'ukraine fait part de
plusieurs cyber attaques oui alors on va
rester prudent à ce stade parce qu'il ya
que nos confrères de reuters pour le
mans qui relaie cette information qui
sera issu d'un ministre ukrainien mais
en tout cas effectivement les sites
internet du gouvernement du parlement du
ministère des affaires étrangères en
ukraine serait donc inaccessible bloqué
ce qu'on appelle le le déni de service
et également des banques seraient
également touchés par cette nouvelle
attaque informatique nouvelle attaque
parce que on se souvient évidemment
qu'il y en a eu il ya une quinzaine de
jours maintenant donc d'une part il faut
attendre pour voir si cette information
est bel et bien confirmée d'autres
sources d'autre part évidemment et c'est
tout le problème des cyberattaques on ne
sait pas qui a commis ces attaques sont
des hackers ce ça c'est sûr mais après
de quelle nationalité sont ils on ne le
sait pas seulement évidemment dans le
contexte dans lequel on est bien sûr et
puisque ça concerne l'ukraine tous les
regards se tournent vers la russie qui
en plus on le sait a depuis quelques
années maintenant acquis une belle
expertise si je puis dire en la matière
donc si toutes ces informations sont
confirmées ça veut dire que vraiment et
ce n'est pas vraiment étonnant de la
part de du régime de vladimir poutine on
assiste à une guerre hybride si vous
voulez à foix cyberattaques pression
diplomatique et puis déploiement sur le
sol d'unités militaires qui font suite
donc à la reconnaissance par vladimir
poutine de l'indépendance des deux
républiques autoproclamées vous restez
avec nous bruno nous allons à